cette vidéo est sponsorisé par Nord VPN
pour les fêtes rendez-vous sur Nord VPN.
Org pour obtenir un abonnement de 2 ans
+ 1 mois supplémentaire gratuit le tout
avec une énorme réduction satisfait ou
remboursé pendant les 30 premiers jours
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ton nouvel épisode de et vous
démerdes je rappelle très bien le
concept à vendre à me contacter un petit
mot sur le titre quand même j'ai reçu
des messages un message là c'était la
personne m'a dit voilà qu'est-ce que tu
fais mais je vais arrêter de suivre
parce qu'on fait à chaque fois que je
vois et vous démerde ça je me sens je me
sens humiliée et donc voilà ça me rend
triste très sincèrement c'est pas du
tout le bus tu prends les choses avec
légèreté distance c'est juste le nom du
président américain
parce que sinon après ça devient une
insulte et c'est pas marrant donc si
vous vous sentez insulté je suis désolé
vraiment c'est rappelez-vous que c'est
juste le titre d'un format et par
ailleurs je le précise ne l'utilisez pas
en dehors de se faire mais pour les gens
qui viennent d'arriver mais qu'est-ce
que c'est des merdes de quoi on va
parler bah c'est très simple vous m'avez
envoyé plein d'histoires vous avez
envoyé des histoires de anonyme vous
avez si possible préciser votre genre
votre âge exetera vous avez envoyé sur
l'adresse mail ci-dessous via le service
d'anonymisation que je mets en
description si vous utilisez pas ce
service la mode histoire n'est pas
sélectionné quoi qu'il arrive mon
acolyte qui va regarder les différentes
histoire me faire une petite sélection
et vous l'envoyer c'est celle qu'on va
découvrir la ensemble mais évidemment si
vous connaissez autre histoire et si je
vous dis que vous êtes une merde vous
êtes une merde après c'est juste mon
avis et c'est dans le contexte de cette
histoire là ça veut pas dire que vous
êtes une merde manière générale et
vice-versa parce que dans une histoire
vous n'êtes pas une merde que de manière
générale dans votre vie de merde et
maintenant que les choses sont dites je
pense qu'on peut commencer à se poser la
question et tu démerdes
[Musique]
si j'ai une merde pour faire
systématiquement semblant d'écouter ma
copine quand elle me parle
waouh j'ai hâte de lire cette histoire
avec ma copine nous avons eu un passé
compliqué nous sommes séparés de
nombreuses fois seulement toujours
ça fait 6 ans que notre relation existe
[Musique]
oui les gens qui font des efforts et
tout ça ça bravo depuis mon changement
j'ai pris l'habitude de me faire un peu
plus discret pour la laisser s'exprimer
lors de nos conversations bravo c'est
bien ça aussi mais voilà j'ai découvert
un vrai moulin à paroles de pas
loin de tout et tout le monde je
comprends
et c'est
alors que je ne connais même pas
tu es une fille extraordinaire que
j'aime de tout mon cœur mais je n'ose
pas lui dire que c'est Ragot ben je m'en
bats la race
assistant seul qu'elle parle à personne
et qu'elle a besoin de parler c'est
important c'est important c'est
important depuis cet espace et c'est
cool de ta part de lui offrir ce qui se
passe à quel point c'est temporaire
aussi voilà désolé et tout et
voilà
parce que
je te comprends
pas
ce que
[Musique]
tu
penses que
en fait tu voudras plus la voir parce
que là je pense qu'il faut lui dire
parce que ça fait que
et que ça risque de
dirais d'attendre d'arriver un point de
retour maintenant si tu penses que tu
peux prendre sur toi et que juste tu as
perdu pas bises et bon bah attends
patiente voilà bon courage mais en tout
cas tu es pas une merde suis-je un
connard de ne pas dire mais parce que
j'ai perdu ma mère salut salut mon
garçon de 20 ans j'ai perdu ma mère il y
a plus de énorme ambiance
[Musique]
Je suis actuellement en études
supérieures j'ai donc été amené
rencontré pas mal de personnes je tenue
très proches avec certaines personnes de
mon école tellement proches que je sais
pas mal de trucs à mon problème est que
j'ai beaucoup de mal à parler du fait
que j'ai perdu ma mère pas que ce soit
douloureux pour moi d'en parler je sais
pas trop comment aborder ce sujet il
faut que j'en ai parlé la conversation
et ultra gênant et ses expériences m'ont
incité à cacher c'est assez de ma vie
j'essaie de faire des blagues pour
montrer que j'étais pas gêné alors que
c'était tout l'inverse dans un ami à qui
j'en parlais très souvent et avec qui je
suis devenu pote donc ça toujours pas il
m'est même arrivé de mentir au sujet de
ma mère en faisant comme si elle était
toujours envie juste pour éviter le
sujet parce que je ne veux pas que les
contractions deviennent gênante le pire
c'est que j'attends pour leur dire
qu'ils vont tomber de haut quand ils
vont la prendre à part oui c'est ça je
suis un connard de ne pas dire à mes
potes que j'ai perdu ma vie selon moi
non pas du tout un connard pour ça faut
réfléchir à pourquoi tu vois parce que
tu mens juste le fait de mentir ne fait
pas trop tard pour moi - même si je le
prends toujours la vérité même si je
fais tout pour toujours dit la vérité
pas pour ça que je condamne tous les
mensonges j'ai fait de mal à personne
toi et te protège toi protège ton
histoire personnelle commence maintenant
oui je te déconseille de mytho parce que
comme tu le dis tu vas attendre que ça
va être dur et ça va te mettre dans des
situations
c'est quoi franchement la limite si tu
as peur du moment gênant le par message
par message machin t'explique tout de A
à Z voilà je l'ai pas fait parce que
comme tu viens de le faire là je t'ai
pas fait parce que j'ai peur de manger
normal je
veux
vraiment
que je te souhaite beaucoup de bonheur
et j'espère que tu vas
très fort
je suis avec ma meilleure amie je vais
toujours
bien prêt à être étudié
cela ne me coûte rien du tout
je n'ai pas envie qu'elle rate son ami
je souhaite de réussir mais je l'ai plus
en plus je pourrais lui dire la vérité
mais je n'ai pas envie qu'elle se dise
que je suis égoïste donc je lui manque
une merde
un peu
et continue comme ça j'adore tes vidéos
merci merci un peu un peu parce qu'en
fait que ça change ça change toi est-ce
que les les notes des résumés les fiches
toi tu les fais quoi qu'il arrive
donc c'est que quelqu'un profite de ton
travail mais si c'est ta meilleure amie
tu l'aurais fait quoi qu'il arrive je
serai juste un truc des gosses parce que
c'est pas un truc de se sentir utilisé
tu vois se sentir un peu manipuler à
manipuler
utiliser un peu de la merde ça
change rien pour toi est toujours
disponible
prends bats les steaks j'ai pas dit
est-ce que je suis un peu là j'ai
encore une fois je te comprends
franchement tu étais le seul qui t'a une
fois 2 fois 3 fois
un
petit peu parce que je
suis en couple
par exemple
alors que je suis en couple avec une
autre
personne pas pour sortir avec eux mais
seulement parce que j'aime bien la
journée qui sont amoureux de moi
j'imagine en couple avec eux avant de
m'endormir parfois de coucher avec le
mais ça s'arrête là car je veux pas
réellement être avec mes crush est où
trompé mon ma partenaire suis une merde
et parfois m'imaginer une autre vie
d'une certaine manière tromper la
personne que j'aime pas du tout mais pas
du tout qui se passe dans votre tête ça
reste dans votre tête c'est il y a bien
un endroit où tu peux penser ce que tu
veux passer là et ça ça ne regarde
personne ça ne regarde que toi tu fais
du mal à personne quand imaginons des
choses si c'est ta petite soupape c'est
ça permet de t'évader exetera ce que tu
as envie d'un peu de d'autres choses
parfois dans ta tête mais vas-y fais-toi
plaisir déjà parlé dans le précédent
épisode de vous démerder comme la
masturbation en fait imagine-toi plein
de choses l'imagination c'est fait pour
ça va réagir comme ça quand elle se
déshabille et j'ai pas lu l'histoire
mais je pense Bonjour j'ai un garçon de
25 ans qui te déteste les poils
next je passe où j'ai été là j'en ai
25 ans il adore l'eau mais il déteste
les poils ok ok chacun ses angoisses moi
c'est la moisissure sur les cookies
une relation avec quelqu'un parce que
c'est le cas je vais être intégralement
à l'avance
c'est ainsi que je me trouve
une totale confiance en moi
et
voilà
c'est
tout ce que je peux pour qu'on fasse
autre chose n'importe quoi mais pas
l'amour
pour me faire plaisir OK
changer son corps pour correspondre aux
attentes des hommes surtout de nos jours
les filles sont en permanence face à des
gens qui leur dise quoi faire de leur
corps fréjus très juste alors je l'ai
laissé dans l'ignorance la plus totale
et je n'ai jamais répondu honnêtement
ancien demandé ce qui s'est passé ce
soir là je vais sûrement la même chose à
chaque fois que cette question il y aura
de nouveau depuis elle est en colère
elle me parle plus je suis une merde bon
complexe et de surcroît très intéressant
déjà je suis dit la même chose c'est
quand ça
arrivera de ouf avec mon pote ça va
arriver prépare-toi en fait je me sens
tellement loin tu vois tu es une merde
pense pas que tu me racontes sur le fait
que tu as pas envie que tu
comprends très bien et
toi parce que
peut-être tu vois
peut-être
par exemple
par exemple tu
dis voilà
mon délire c'est pas de poils quoi si
toi ça te pose un problème a pas de
souci on se voit pas quoi si toi tu as
des poils ah non c'est chaud
parce que je me disais genre tel que tu
me l'expliquer la de manière très clair
on est en bas là j'ai pas envie que tu
changes que tu es pour moi machin mais
s'il s'avère que fait le problème c'est
que si tu lui dis ça après tu enchaînes
avec quoi manger avec s'il s'avère que
tu as des poils ça va pas être possible
ça le problème et toi est-ce que c'est
le cas avec tout tu vois est-ce que par
exemple tu as le même blocage en façon
la taille des seins en fonction des
fesses en fonction je sais pas des
taches de rousseur j'en sais rien tu
vois c'est très spécifique et ça vaut le
coup sans dire que c'est grave pas du
tout mais sauf si tu te rends compte que
ça te bloque et que ça t'empêche de
faire les rencontres
sur ce sujet un professionnel
après quand
on sera jamais vraiment ce que c'est
est-ce que
c'est est-ce que tu avais besoin de te
retrouver
c'est que tu dis cette situation il y
aura de nouveau une broussaille un truc
vraiment Macif on parle de trucs qui
déborde ça arrive pas souvent sur toi il
faut du temps pour que ça pousse souci
mais non parce que tu as bien conscience
que voilà
donc c'est cool mais
je pense que tu es
et que ça te fait souffrir
j'espère que tu trouves quelqu'un
qui soit que tu arrives sur ce truc là
et que ce ne soit plus
je suis une femme j'ai 24 ans je n'ai
jamais été en couple et pourtant j'ai
déjà eu des fleurs et je ne suis pas
vierge parfois le manque d'affection me
fait souffrir et la plupart du temps je
le vis bien
je ne vois pas l'intérêt d'être en
couple seulement pour ne pas être
avec
moi
je le trouve drôle intelligente un jeu
de discussion
seulement il a une femme je le sais
c'est même déjà saluer mais on se
connait pas plus elle ne vient jamais au
soir et elle est casanière leur couple
va mal je connaissais déjà ces infos
avant le début du fleurs tu veux qu'on
est proche depuis quelques années et
aussi 2 enfants
10 et 12 ans il a 37 ans ou à 13 ans
plus que moi donc il avait ton âge.
Fruits à côté voilà
technique je dis non parce que c'est un
peu trop loin de chez moi prendre le bus
et tout au bout de quelques soirées
passées avance j'ai expliqué que je ne
serai jamais la maîtresse de quelqu'un
dans plus qu'il a des enfants c'est un
peu gênant les deux trois soirées mais
c'est vite passé notre relation et
redevient amis car j'imagine que tu
m'écris c'est que ça s'est pas arrêté la
7 mois se sont écoulés
depuis 2 mois sachant que on est amené à
se voir au moins une fois par semaine on
est proche de couche ensemble mais c'est
de barrière ultime n'a pas été franchie
car je refuse encore catégoriquement je
ne sais pas expliquer ce que je ressens
je crois pas que ce soit des sentiments
amoureux mais une attirance physique et
émotionnelle et bien présent il me dit
des choses qui me font je n'arrive pas à
résister mon ego en as besoin quelle
lucidité on adore et je sais pas quand
est-ce que c'est trop tard il y a un
petit temps de latence mais c'est pour
ça que des trucs que j'ai toujours dit à
Tom c'est prends toujours des histoires
qui sont fini parce que on a pas envie
en fait j'ai pas envie d'avoir un impact
en fait trop fort sur ce que vous
pourriez faire j'aime juger des choses
qui sont passés qui sont finis s'il ne
se passe rien à une soirée je cherche à
le provoquer
je pense à moi
pour le moment
j'ai
besoin d'être
intelligent
ils sont pas dans ton cercle d'amis
parce que parce que si ça se passe mal
dans le cercle d'amis et tout là il
éclate tu as l'air d'adorer c'est ça que
c'est dommage donc
tu es pas tu es pas une merde parce que
tu as passé des autres trucs et encore
on attend
la merde c'est
la merde
voilà
voilà voilà
ce
que toi
tu
veux pas du tout
voilà il faut penser à tout ça si c'est
juste pour un coup d'un soir
effectivement c'est peut-être beaucoup
de culpabilité et tout j'ai l'impression
que il y a des gens qui sont fous les
gens qui ont pas de culpabilité parce
que je peux avoir ce genre de chose bon
je comprends que ça te gêne tu m'as
envoyé un message si on a une pour moi
c'est un peu plus lui c'est lui après
voilà
salut je suis
une personne
en fait j'étais
avec des
amis et je
suis tombée amoureuse
aujourd'hui et je vais faire mes courses
parce que clairement les aliments à base
de poisson fermenté sauce d'huître pâte
de crevette poisson séché salé sauce
d'anchois shiokara un plat avec ce type
d'ingrédients c'est pour moi un vrai
délice j'adore ça et j'en mange assez
souvent dans ma nouvelle coloc mes goûts
culinaires ne sont pas comme au début
mais que le pénis d'odeur de poisson
pourri ou de poubelle comme si de rien
n'était je sais ce qu'il soit bien forcé
te rends compte que c'est moi qui mange
ça
qui pue
ils ont continué de se parler je leur ai
expliqué que c'est un genre de condiment
qui ajoute du goût au plat et que plein
de gens mon chat en Asie pas même
proposé de goûter des collègues tu
trouves ça drôle et ont goûté mais
continue me vanner régulièrement avec
deux autres en particulier c'est plus
compliqué hein m'a expliqué qu'il
trouvait que je te fais pas cuisinier
dans un clan aussi odorant dans les
espaces communs par respect pour les
autres
nous avons discuté je vais essayer de
faire un maximum après que je cuisine je
les ai déjà écoute je te propose
d'ouvrir les fenêtres une fois qu'on a
mangé ok cool tu faisais pas jusqu'à
maintenant si je te propose de conseille
de faire ce que
l'autre a carrément pété un plomb ah
ouais un jour en rentrant dans la
cuisine et a déclaré que ce n'est plus
possible et qu'il allait en parlant pour
te calmes le propriétaire n'a pas réagi
personnellement je trouve que j'ai droit
de manger ce que je veux et sinon j'ai
envie mais oui cela est pour moi un vrai
et je serais vraiment que c'est bon que
c'est comestible et c'est pas vraiment
du poisson pourri donc d'en manger une à
deux fois par semaine mais je sens bien
que ça dérange beaucoup au fond je suis
une merde car je continue de manger du
poisson pourri non il n'est pas une
merde parce que tu manges du poisson
pourri tu as mangé du poisson pourri
alors ça serait cool effectivement
trouver des solutions pour que la vie en
communauté se passe bien aéré exetera
donc une fois que tu as mangé du poisson
mettre du papier d'Arménie dansant
je sais pas écrire au propriétaire
est-ce que tu manges du poisson pourri
extrême
est-ce que c'est le bateau qui veut que
j'adore aussi.
On t'embrasse tous tous et j'espère que
vous ai trouvé une solution notamment
pour ce dernier colloque
souvent des 2e 3e
personne
en anglais
[Musique]
envoyer les vis en France seul sans
famille son visa expert dans 2 mois je
ne sais pas si l'obtention d'un diplôme
pour lui permettre d'être il m'explique
qu'il veut continuer les études
d'informatique à la fac et que s'il
obtient un diplôme il pourrait entrer
j'en doute mais il n'a pas le niveau
vraiment pas et ça serait injuste
vis-à-vis de tous les autres candidats
de lui donner difficile d'avoir la vie
des gens sur les mains comme ça je lui
ai pas donné le diplôme sujet de merde
assez dur à ça va être dur comme
j'habite à voir c'est terrible mais la
vie est dure quoi la vie est dure mais
pour moi tu es pas une merde tu es pas
une merde quoi tu vois genre tu as fait
ton job en fait tu as fait ton job assez
dur ça allait durcisse toi tu as raison
tu as raison quand tu dis que c'est
juste pour tous les autres candidats
exetera c'est vrai que c'est pas parce
que il as pas c'est là qu'il faut
forcément j'ai donné ce diplôme tu vois
parce que après j'imagine que ça fait
perdre la valeur au diplôme du coup le
diplôme il vaut plus rien du coup tout
ce qu'ils ont ce diplôme tous ceux qui
viennent de l'avoir bah ils peuvent
aller nulle part ça fout la merde quoi
j'imagine et surtout s'il a pas le
niveau du tout ce que tu as fait
Benjamin et que si tu l'avais pas fait
on l'aurait fait plus tard en fait un
autre niveau tu vois au-dessus de 3 ans
plus tard et le gars se retrouve à
devoir abandonner tu vois peut-être j'en
sais rien c'est très difficile à dire
mais en tous les cas je pense pas que tu
sois une merde voilà j'espère que ce
réfugié politique as pu trouver d'autres
solutions qu'il a pu trouver d'autres
structures d'accueil exetera voilà qu'il
a pu commencer des études d'informatique
à la fac autrement c'est pas la
meilleure je sais pas très difficile
c'est des questions j'imagine la
culpabilité que tu peux ressentir mais
pour moi tu es pas une merde pour moi tu
es pas une merde tu as fait ton taf
alors après c'est pas parce que juste
c'est ton taf et qu'il faut l'exécuter
bêtement tu vois on pourrait dire
ça fait penser à la banalité du mal
Arendt exetera qui parlait de la défense
des officiers c'est ce qu'il dit voilà
moi j'ai juste exécuter les ordres sont
les ordres que je te dis que tu es pas
une merde en fait c'est un ordre et ce
système il a du sens tu vois c'est le
système de diplôme c'est un cursus
scolaire c'est pour juste par rapport
aux autres exetera tout ça se défend en
fait
donc c'est pas juste parce que tu as
fait ton taf et
malheureusement il arrive que tu sais
principes
de merde
c'était
vraiment très fort
tu révises cette question suis une merde
à chier dans un carton de travail
volontairement pour regarder mes
collègues
là en fait par rapport au titre je sais
vraiment pas comment synthétiser
pas mal c'était pendant mon premier job
j'étais réceptionniste hôtel 4 étoiles
en CDD ça c'était pas super bien passé
parce que je sombrai dans la dépression
= beaucoup moi j'avais des problèmes
d'alcool je prenais des cachets
anxiolytique et antidépresseur du coup
c'est délicat parce que j'avais dû
prendre un arrêt maladie de un mois et
demi ne pas me en l'air content
que tu sois pas foutu en l'air en arrêt
maladie mes collègues me fait comprendre
qu'il m'en voulais d'avoir été absent et
on m'a reproché d'avoir quelques
troubles mentaux pas très sympa les
collègues 58 un mal se passer pour
plusieurs raisons fait perdre prêt de
10000 € à l'hôtel par mégarde le jour de
Noël
[Musique]
de nuit j'ai décidé d'en parler à un
collègue avec qui je m'entendais très
bien de chier dans un carton et le
laisser pourrir est enfermé tout le coin
fumeur donc je l'ai fait je suis
retrouvée accroupi dehors à chier dans
un fou du carton juste pour laisser une
petite trace de moi et pas des moindres
aux gens qui ont été condescendant parce
que je souffre de dépression perso à ce
jour ultra selon toi c'est une merde
je sais pas quoi en penser parce que je
pense à la personne qui nettoie cette
merde c'est la vraie vie c'est la
personne qui a fait cette merde et qui
n'a rien demandé si cette personne était
un ou une collègue qui se moque de toi
mais ça je sais pas ça la réponse à
cette question je change beaucoup de
merde maintenant même si quelqu'un qui
n'a rien demandé nettoyer de merde on
sort mais mais par contre se foutent de
la gueule de quelqu'un qui a une
dépression on peut ne pas s'en faire
chier dans le carton c'est vraiment
grave c'est drôle tu es pas une merde et
j'espère on espère que tu vas mieux
quoi
tout à l'heure attends il faut que je
présente quelqu'un
Cyrus north VPN oui c'est moi mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait un vieux
et
[Musique]
voilà
et
pour faire croire que je suis pas là où
je suis
c'est simple d'utilisation
merde on n'a pas trop envie que tout le
monde le sache et cetera voilà on est
tous un peu de manière anonyme et tout
machin d'où l'esprit un peu non je
trouve que ça c'est hyper bien mais un
truc que j'ai dit une fois et que j'ai
pas dit d'ailleurs
j'ai essayé tous les voilà celui que
j'ai utilisé le plus le plus rapide et
le plus fiable
si vous allez
vous allez trouver une promo
j'en ai plein. Com et en plus c'est
pour ça que
[Musique]
ajouté en toute transparence j'espère
que cette vidéo vous aura plu j'espère
qu'elle vous aura intéressé j'espère
qu'elle vous aura fait rire on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
autre vidéo n'hésitez pas à balancer vos
histoires en disant le lien dans la
description avec l'adresse mail que je
mets dans la description voilà balancer
vos histoires les plus folles c'est un
plaisir de vous lire et de partager avec
vous j'adore ce format vous allez tout
le monde aime se forme sur la semaine
prochaine love
ciao et à toutes celles de ceux qui sont
reconnus dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui je
vous embrasse très fort gros bisous
[Musique]